let's get into audience questions for
the week our
first post-trump set of questions
in the joe biden era there's something
in the air
that's just seeming a little different
uh but let's get right into it and
a lot of these questions really go to
sort of seeking to understand where we
are as a country right now and i think
that these all tie together very well
the first one is david now with trump in
the rear view
how did trump change the country and how
did he not and and i think this is
really the perfect question to start to
understand what happened
uh donald trump did not as as near as i
can tell
create racists or racism
create xenophobes who want to stop
immigration
from so-called [ __ ] countries what he
did was
he coalesced these groups of people and
he made them more comfortable
being public about it the things that
used to be whispered
behind closed doors by people who had
some sense that while this is what i
believe
i recognize i'll probably be looked down
upon in most circles if i say it out
loud
they were welcomed into saying these
things
out loud but it's important to
understand that that is a change
not not creating racism may be an area
where there was not a change under trump
but the racism being more open is a
change
under donald trump and along those lines
the changes we really saw
under trump include of course degrading
the public discourse degrading
what counts as acceptable political
debate
and what counts as acceptable in a
political campaign
in terms of particular types of insults
not only about your political opponents
but
you know ridiculing disabilities
ridiculing
uh deceased members of the military
there was nothing beyond
the pale uh be uh it was beyond the pale
that there was nothing that trump
saw as off the table i think better said
in terms of what and how you can
criticize others
and the change trump made and we'll see
if it gets changed again but it could be
an irreversible change
trump removed whatever was left of the
idea of american exceptionalism we
really sucked
during the last four years in ways that
many americans
wrongly but many americans previously
thought
would only happen in other countries or
only happened in other countries and it
turns out that
what we learned is that the united
states is just like any other place
really terrible corrupt people can get
into power
that corruption and weaponization can
get into
law enforcement it can get into the
military it can get into all aspects of
government
it can interfere with science it can
infect even
you know nasa and all of these other
things and that is a change
now the things that didn't change during
trump's presidency
are also cause for concern
what do i mean by that well how did
trump get
to be the republican nominee and
ultimately become president
the structure of anti-intellectualism
and reactionary politics not based in
fact
are partially what got donald trump into
power that hasn't changed
in fact i would argue it's worse than
ever and it's been particularly
weaponized
by the explosion of right-wing extreme
media like newsmax and oan
and q anon stuff and others uh
the electoral college got trump into
power
that hasn't changed so another trump
could come into power again
i think if there is what is the most
important message that could be taken
away from the trump presidency because
there are many
um checks and balances aren't nearly as
robust as we thought they were when you
have a madman in the white house
uh elect you know we have all these
different takeaways
the most important takeaway now that
we're looking forward
must be nothing has changed about what
got trump into power in the first place
if anything it's worse as we saw by 75
million people voting for trump in
november
and just as easily as trump got in i
would argue it is even easier for
another trump to get into power
that's the top takeaway so yes
fix gerrymandering get rid of the
electoral college
find a way to democratize the senate
which is so anti-democratic
you've got to deal with campaign finance
put dealing with climate into the law
rather than leaving it to the whims of
political administrations
there's such a long list of things that
have to be done but
if we don't recognize that until we
actually deal with
the culture that got trump
into a position where he could win the
republican primary and eventually the
the presidency it could happen again and
that's
very very scary